pervert
welke like a hurricane hey don't act
like you can't see me you shot me you
shot me in the eye
you shot me the least you could do is
pay attention to me [ __ ] shoot you she
shot me or what if she didn't protect
Birkin did she'd pretend directly I
guess if that's your sense of morality
what are you out what's your inventory
looking like well I have drugs a shoddy
which needs to be convinced that no crap
a green herb more no bullets you're
gonna need the Magnum soonish I don't
have the Magnum why would I have Magnum
I guess I forgot to do anything about it
and I got way more health which I am
personally just thrilled about yeah
unfortunately I don't think I have any
red herbs but I do have a decent amount
of blue oh [ __ ] and green sorry I'm
doing a bad job I'd like to put this
back so I should probably use my Magnum
which means I need to get it we have
magnum rounds above it too right I will
combine those cool wait a minute
Oh someone told me on Facebook that
shotgun parts upgrade your shotgun yeah
I was gonna say confine him you forgot
to mention that well you just got them I
got them last episode I could have done
in last episode well you could honey I
don't think you ever be able to use it
the point all right should I combine any
of these it's not don't I would get rid
of the first day spray for now I'm just
saying like I have all these herbs I
could combine ring one green herb but
shouldn't I combine them you might run
into a red herb in the next hallway you
never know
oh right that should be good okay so
this is a good load here I feel pretty
good about this a handgun I think a good
set of the instead sucks and train
remember if you bring me if you have
another stop before you need the Magnum
I think you're good for now okay bring a
shotgun I have a shotgun it's equipped
so I'm gonna come in my shotgun now yes
see shotgun combat see shotgun see I do
see it see you shotgun see shotgun shoot
see shotgun killed zombie it's going
well hey hey girl
we're never gonna finish this game yeah
this is it
we're at we're at like the tail end here
I feel pretty good all right where we
gonna go to more episode of thing like
yeah I've been saying that the last four
episodes yeah that's it all right
I don't think I've been you came from
the ladder yeah so this is this is new
through here
I'm so excited
Oh all this is new when we got here some
barrels oh [ __ ]
yeah just
mm what are you trained
all right I would like to board not to
like jump the gun and get people excited
but I think this weekend I'm playing
through resin evil 3 as a refresher oh
not letting you come over though it
seems to be a control device for the
turntable I'm gonna look over you're
gonna be spying through my window trying
to prep I would love to prep also
because we're doing extra life next
weekend I'm trying to convince Mike to
play a Resident Evil game with me
long-form through extra life but he said
no because no numbered entries that were
save an effort knievel well we can play
like you know we could do we go Claire B
scenario in this game but I took well
yeah it would be harder but I took there
you know I don't know you don't really
use the UH you can get by that
submachine gun you kind of need every
day that the cPanel key has a D on it
all right so key go in thing that means
okay my way train we could play zero the
remaster I wonder if we can I wonder if
there's any way to like go back through
the stream afterward the week after and
then cut out episodes from zero oh I
will do that I'm gonna be a bonus
episode for you I shouldn't be I
shouldn't be like we should we should
talk about us off camera no I care those
watching you don't know wha change like
the marathon that we raised money to
donate to Children's Hospitals and if
you want us to play a game of your
choice then you should not just say in
the comments but tweet at me Mary Kish
em er ry k is H or mama Hardy mom mm a
hearty UFC fighter mama mama Hardy
because we can make that happen for the
kids
will you push the activation switch you
bet your buns you bet your buns that's
annoying you just activate the Train
already yeah would you want me to do if
if there's like a red button I'm gonna
push it if there's a keyhole I'm gonna
put a key in it unless someone like
yells otherwise no I'm still upset about
it it makes complete sense this Minds me
the Polar Express I haven't seen that
movie never you never hear my hear that
Bell and I believe that's my Tom Hanks
impression hey tonight oh no it's that
thing again
a tie just got killed oh she breathes it
happened really quick and wait for
resident 3 @ 4 & 5 3 I've not played
much is he gonna fight me fight me
Shia South you damn creature show your
face alright
I guess he's outside should I look in
the hole it's a hole so you like
depressing red buttons it is I thought
you liked depressing red bones you know
there's no right oh where button in case
of emergency the red light will turn on
and access from outside will be
prohibited for a limited time
Oh got your time get that bag I'm ready
demon hmm it's a two-dimensional
gingerbread man with arms in his stomach
he's got extra arm and a beard of
tentacles wait a new evil skull and an
eyeball and cause made a Wolverine metal
stop adding to it I didn't make the game
you should get your Magnum up really
[ __ ] him up yeah okay there's seven
shots or so Oh
skeet skeet wait that's not used in this
situation is it sure with the face Boosh
oh he attacked me you should sprint
around backup is too slow nice do you
think I'm actually I'm amazed it sorry
I'm sorry sorry you can probably do that
one greener would be set yeah
Joe wait now I use a green one you don't
want to risk it you feel sitting on your
biscuit never having to risk it ah why
why are you doing this to me reload that
smoke wagon what's going on I had a
headache a way that feels shitty oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] I keep [ __ ] him up [ __ ] him up
I'm working on it mm-hmm we're kissing
either one shut up I'm sorry that wasn't
this is mine you still in caution I
think you're good Jesus me I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry okay I'm sorry
use the [ __ ] first day I'm doing a
bad job listen I don't have fears all
right red and green spot turning around
takes a long time that's what that's
where this issues happening that's my
problem it's okay should I go to the
other side you only got a few more shots
but do what you want whatever feels good
I think it's a dead end
oh my god oh yeah I run this way I was
just trying to finish him off [ __ ] him
up no sorry sorry it's okay yeah huh
crap yeah oh he's coming still it's like
a Black Knight no he's dead
show yourself where'd he go
I didn't know that his eyeballs are
still on the tip of that dude's claws oh
my god I can't believe I got hurt check
his pulse I'm sorry he's got blood
coming on we got a lot of health that
was like the one of the big gut checks
the game I guess he had the magnets here
good I just couldn't I couldn't turn
fast enough he's really hard to turn
alright nothing he's got nothing on him
alright well that wasn't so bad it
killed him yeah you got him it was
pretty cool I was a neat looking bad guy
you know and it took the kitchen sink
approaches gave him everything but never
like a cyclops I Wolverine claws go nuts
extra arms like Shiva Arms in the middle
an eagle head a regular head of Zeus
beard of tentacles Zeus peered now what
am i doing is this like a loading scene
yeah you have to go check on the dot hey
girl hey I took like eight shots more
than you you got herself up onto the
come on caught that's correct
first to finish that sentence you did
though that's what matters
um their honeymoon he's breaking her to
the bedroom around Raccoon City in the
penthouse suite they're all actually
it's the dungeon suite but they gave us
a discount at the front desk
I told me bring flowers down they
brought me this was the right room free
the shaft room the shaft type the shaft
type Magnum yeah we're married I'm
taking her to the shaft room see you in
two days the honeymoon suite comes with
a hot tub a sauna ticket bathrobes and
in the shower these sexy ladies in the
back rooms definitely a shaft room no
told you it's my job to look after you I
love you but you'll be in danger if you
stay with me period of time but I really
enjoy being
I playing him like a fiddle I know I'm
not capable of caring about anyone lose
you straight shooter
yeah we're leaving this place together
wait here for me I'll be right back
I was gonna make fun of what she said
but she said it so literally like I
can't like I can't be like I'm incapable
of caring but anyone but myself that
that's like literally what she said so
there's no reason to do it she's pretty
narcissistic at least she's honest she's
got those back sick all right
there's also a plant but do you think I
should be taking all this stuff yeah
nice I've already made back at third of
your to help you spend yeah I'm doing
pretty well
oh you know what someone else told me
can you go backwards or is this as far
as we go
what do you mean can we go back up up
yeah eventually but right now no I don't
think so
okay you could try like I never think I
never did later a reason I ask is
because I think someone else had
mentioned that if you like that flare
gun you get other stuff that's right so
we should do that if we can okay
Oh at the top of it yeah that's correct
do I need anything else should I save I
have a decent amount of saving yeah you
should you might as well
saving pucks fight William again I'm
just gonna save cuz there's no reason
not to like it's I if you say if what
you say is true and it's gonna take two
episodes this one included right so like
this one and one more
you might even yeah like beat it today
like this one yeah you'll figure it out
yeah I'll do it
we could go an extra twenty minutes or
something let's do it then ultimate and
also his last episode if we do it now
the wound anyway what I'm saying is I
have a [ __ ] ton of pucks to spare so I
might as well save like like hockey
pucks is that what you're calling those
now they look like hawks
tell me that doesn't look like a puck
the Montreal ink ribbons a Stanley Cup
against that the San Jose more bullets
all right wait I don't know there's
something attached that I needed okay I
bring a submachine gun I I don't know my
guess on oh I don't have to I can bring
a bag
okay alright let's collect our bearings
here we're at map I haven't been through
a few these doors right I haven't been
through that Scout the platform for [ __ ]
okay you know that way that way or come
back this way first I'm gonna take the
main shaft oh hold on
before I go look around the Train first
I think call it that
I think you're good I can check the
other side though take it on the other
side I'm sorry dude no I feel fine
you know loopy I want to like brag or
anything and I hope you don't take it
that way but I've never had a migraine
in my life so I don't know what it feels
like you're relating to me really well
right I know I'm sorry
really close sorry you know so naturally
I'm in a house they had a room staring
at two screens an elevator pressing the
button has no effect it hasn't been used
for a long time
elevator I hardly know I'm trying to say
is that's all I see do you see anything
else what I was trying to say is I don't
understand
so I empathize with you based on no
knowledge which i think is a thing yeah
that's a good thing that's empathy
sympathy is like I don't understand but
it doesn't mean I don't feel bad about
it that's a super eerie shot ah spider
robot engage what is it I was kidding a
huge breaker system that regulates all
the power in the lab the main fuse has
been removed and the power is not active
in some areas okay it's hard to see in
here and I actually sure
oh there's another blue door
take the blue path in the red path
simple enough is that it though there's
only two paths there's also that path
right three came from great okay that's
cool that's a cool way to do this all
right I'm gonna do blue first the lines
are painted on the floor timesplitters
perfect it's a weird thing you remember
I want to play time squares to for extra
life I have to hear zombies blue yeess I
thought you said we see this shutter is
sealed firmly in place East area door I
opened with a card key East area east
area ice milk to make oil burning
tobacco this looks broken
yeah I'm in the ice cube also known as a
freezer control box used to four super
low temperature experiments I could set
the super Domino fuse here if I had a
fuse case so I need a fuse case fuse
case yeah fuse now what a puzzle I still
need first aid scribe back right here oh
thank you delightful friend
I think that's it go back to the machine
again I think it's gonna just say yeah
you me the fuse for the fuse kit I can
try I have a fuse case should I try it
I'll try it yeah I don't I think you
need to sweet okay make it turn the
power back on I think but I think you
need to hurry or else it warms up too
much the first one is this the thing
like in the first game where I can't run
or shoot don't believe so will you take
the main fuse hey check it when you get
the chance okay I think you're just a
lot less items in this game this like
remake and remaster a little more
complicated in their puzzles than this
game this game's more about shooting it
back I can restore the power to the lab
with this that's all it says doesn't say
anything about being careful yeah just
go for it it's the most wonderful time
yeah it's like doesn't it's not like
warning me that I'm gonna splode or
anything well that's all it's so bad
all right do you think I should go to
the West area or do you think I should
just turn the power back on turn the
power on just get rid of the fuse that
makes more sense
I am oh yeah so I just pop it in there
show you the red area first or should I
finish the key card yet
alright I thought it was power related
that makes more sense
shaft
who
stop it's a shudder switch will you push
it
no I'm not ready yet
oh I can't without the power on you
wouldn't it be oh ah but who locked it
just not many people left alive what's
that noise
the computer don't think I won't kill
you
no it's like an ice skater come on
I played a Michelle Kwan a scenario
that's who lacked at that anemone that
octopi temporary user registration for
the culture experiment room user name is
guest all caps by the way password none
with capitalized in guests none got it
is that you're joking or do you actually
think the password is none none check
his body no so there's this body
compared to every other body became like
that's not actually a character model
it's just part of the nice she thought
don't I want to don't waste bullets
don't let it touch you it looks like a
port oil all over the place oh I could
light him on fire light him up [ __ ] now
sure I just don't want to be in the oil
in my defense
that was my alien life whoa you're in
the hot seat plant I don't think I need
any more blue plants well that's you
can't take those that's just the two oh
right you're right those are the two
time users check those lockers though
okay
those look like beds what are those
hotels called the pod to kit pod hotels
thank you yeah yeah yeah I I almost went
to them when I went there but I was
afraid I just felt like i wouldnt be
able to sleep no I wouldn't either
laboratory security manual in the
instance of an inn can in uncontainable
biohazardous break out all security
measures will be directed towards an
underground transport facility in the
instance that any abnormalities are
detected among cargo and transit all
materials will automatically be
transported from the loading zone to the
designated high-speed train at which
point all materials will be isolated and
disposed of immediately in the instance
of a class one emergency the entire
train will be purged and disposed of
without delay in the instance that the
lab itself become contaminated the
northern most route currently used for
transport materials to and from the
facility will be designated this is it a
lot yes I escape routes okay
so you want me to check what it going to
do the computer thing now and then check
the lockers will you turn on the switch
okay now what oh maybe that's not
thinking I was thinking
should we open another door now oh my
god I didn't ask you if I should take
that cuz it's too cool not to I had to
overrule you sure you're not forgetting
the computer used guests on might be
farther down I think it's actually back
in the keycard room it might be double
check okay
there's anything now that powers on
either go down the elevator or you go
back to this locker right now there
click on that vent okay yeah I was gonna
go eat it no flamethrower it what is it
what is it I don't know it's breathing
everything breeze no not true actually
plane oh my god [ __ ] me up ooh maybe
flamethrowers not a shotgun what about
better
yeah you should shock in them heal with
a greener first-day spray maybe and then
shotgun caution what do you think do
green herb and then shotgun but be ready
to use the first stage right you don't
push them away enough yeah
I run this way and then shoot him first
a sprite please yeah thank you yeah
you're good you have plenty of other
herbs [ __ ] stop stop
God they touch you before you can turn
around it's really annoying
alright I'm sorry here we go yeah
flamethrower is my bad whatever no it's
fine it's fine I'm fine
like it's literally fine check the room
for fingerprints
okay I found some hockey pucks those
like watch batteries that's cool though
because that means we can save again and
keep going yeah you want to UM I don't
know what's going on in this room let's
see that's funny it makes you like just
do it again so you like don't get as
much if you don't do it the first time
you're very interesting alright now what
you check the desk that's where the
ribbons were just unlucky don't wanna
leave unless you check the beds I know I
didn't yeah I don't see anything okay
sure
wait so there's this what's this ladder
I needs a bed
and I don't want to go through that you
know they need everything right chat
type medium all right here no wait
so now while the elevator back the
beginning I think now that is power you
go get the keycard expect that make
sense do you think oh yeah I do this
actually
oh is this fire those are plants uh yeah
might as well just make sure you have
distance though no I can't hit them we
discuss this some machine gun shotgun
either one just do it I can't Alec
oh no I got me yeah am i hitting here
that would not guess no I like warm out
of there more and then but they're
spitting acid on me I saw a green goo
yeah yeah this is one of the things yeah
not flame through him now on the ground
he hurt me I know it's a flamethrower
I'm gonna grab this in case you get
[ __ ]
did I do it alright so I'm like [ __ ]
unhealthy now that's horseshit they're
hurting me I don't have any health but
move away from oh [ __ ] I didn't they're
all plants so it's really hard to tell
you know I don't I can't take anymore
unless I eat it you could eat one and
them together what do you think well
wait wait wait I'm on caution you're
coming back up here so well if they're
she's down there that can kill me just
go down yeah it's a [ __ ] there's
plants have it it's like poison ivy
Blair I'm not poisoned my danger
something very
well I just got to say it I just look
like weird vaginas yeah yeah I don't
think you cannot see that
I hear it because where is it he's dumb
as a but I'm gonna kill him
show yourself
[ __ ] if there's a fork I'm gonna be
pissed
first spoons
[ __ ]
that's not good what you want to do all
right
well [ __ ] you the recalls pushing you
back into this camera angle oh I see I
see I'll move a little forward might as
well use that air you got another one
coming up an herb coming up it's right
there at the end of Holland I hear him
do you hear it mm-hmm
I don't understand okay
a big left turn here show yourself you
[ __ ] brain gutless [ __ ] little
life he's a monkey [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] that
is who's he I don't see him
Oh Matt herbes son mad I'm super
confused
alright so left I guess just take it out
in the hallway check that hold on
alright feel like I should kill that
liquor
I don't have that oh [ __ ] buckshot that
was happen really fast
yikes oh god I'm really glad and oh my
god I forgot to like combine my shotgun
I feel like I should save again just
someone just happened
shaft type large you pervert
get your gutter get your mind out of the
gutter no everyone knows what I saw saw
a wall of vagina tentacles and I'm in a
shaft room everyone would agree that
that's what you should think of when you
see that stuff seems only fair a map of
the lab is available yes good all those
wait wait wait wait come back
alright but I can save I can save later
if you think pretty sure you can go on
that monitor I remember the [ __ ] that
gas miners
all right
that's happening is making my headache
worse what's happening
you're safe man yeah
you're happy let's go go go it's amazing
we've only saved 12 times yeah like
doesn't it feel like we've saved like a
hundred times well if we do about a save
in episode ish then I would say there's
like six ish maybe more I'll give her
the submachine gun okay the flamethrower
in case but I really don't think you'll
need that doesn't bring some health oh
all right well I have to go back and get
the health then
you're going back up that way
what do you mean that all the all the
herb EES were in this one yeah you're
going back up here later anyway
so don't get them I don't know get get
them if you want but you're gonna go
back through there I was just saying cuz
like I could get them now and take them
with me suit yourself suit yourself no
stop it oh man gotcha good hi what a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] keeps killing us
feeling alright you think that's enough
do you think I should do more I think
there's three so I could technically
take another one yeah mm-hmm should I
yeah there's a box right near you
all right
man I really needed that health remember
for like two episodes I was like well if
I hurt I'm just screwed because I don't
have any health entire straights
okay just put one away and keep two or
what or I could put two away and take
the first-aid spray
no I just take two for now red one first
it's braised and we take up less space
later on when you need it I feel I feel
eerily confident yeah just this is weird
I feel comfortable there's no beer all
over the place
well that's what makes me feel
comfortable that some things can come
out of the goddamn ceiling dad [ __ ] top
it it doesn't work poison room what's
blue mean you got everything
Oh the dark icky Cardin I don't have a
key card it might not be I mean
double-check your maybe you need ice
missiles huh yeah I don't [ __ ] my thing
don't go okay
okay move though like don't stand still
what do I do
no you stand still though poopin
oh sweet he spit footwork well there's a
writer see spit you at me mine I should
know I will combine that [ __ ] now feel
like red herbs have been short splat
okay so go here here maybe that's you
sure sure I think that's the only place
I can go nope sorry combined I could
open it if I had the key
just go in
there must be more do you have a key
card for me do you have a key card for
daddy what stop son I'm packing serious
heat everyone get your box probably safe
shells just dodging
I haven't used a handgun in years
you tell me game
don't make me guess um I think there's
one more zom there is I should kill them
too right Oh Carter there what is this
this is about the feet all right that's
what I needed you in like two doors do
we need anything else
there's stuff on their desks over there
he's twitching big creep this computer
can you actually move to the right and
use the monitor I don't know the gas
machine might be able to topstitch it
you can kill him if you wanna go search
the desks oh yeah whoop you're dead
suck it okay maybe this computer so you
think there's a computer that I'm
supposed to access so it's probably
upstairs behind the car key door okay
or in the one down here I can remember
it's the gasping all I did a box right
save back save so many times now
where they give me all this stuff makes
me feel like the game's gonna go on
check that thing in the water it there
the room okay
just looked interesting fake out psycho
okay so I have a keycard
there's this down area oh that's nothing
that's interesting
this is level area okay so the first
thing that's just yeah actually that's
why I'm key for that Oh
a key a key okay sorry I don't know
where you get a key
I must be later not really I get on the
turret hallway turtle hallway you
shouldn't need to use it come on I
thought I was in that round I guess so
um this this looks like an incubator
filled with eggs
I've seen a fair amount of those near
time I just know eggs when I see them
oh my god I want to should I light that
[ __ ] on fire let's save it for the thing
to my desk - I see that he's eating my
[ __ ] finish up there's eggs
everywhere heat shotgun he land shotgun
yeah I just I don't understand what the
flamethrower is even good for I got
friggin these dudes on the desk right
there's anything goddammit I run out of
this corner yet did I [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
he's green okay so this is what you're
talking about
think so don't destroy the computer look
kidding
yeah I would I would like to operate
this guest
hold onto your books
oh good
so now what click it again okay um maybe
you can use light on fire No so your
register use would
[ __ ] eggs everywhere it's vile I
don't I have a key card still should I
just go another doors yeah there's that
one upstairs
Jeff [ __ ] burned your mother just go
away
cool
so we're getting there
I think there's some stuff I can
probably put away I wouldn't bring the
flamethrower I'm not gonna bring the
pugs [ __ ] it's not what I meant to do
machine gun actually none of them I
should I bring my gun then okay any help
all right I'm off to save the world
chef
okay don't have that yet
you go that way yep no ya go down there
oh sorry no right no no the hallways
right next to isn't it there's this dog
Oh a mice
oh that's the pillar sorry yeah it's
misleading
all right so no card key door upstairs
needless Patrick it's doesn't need
forgot about you how could I forget
about you it's a big creepy thing what's
not pictured is Leon going Mel your
solid three lighter after you kill the
theory well plants it back
what's with a vengeance why to idiot
what I did towards the camera wait sorry
yeah that's the way you good
yeah all right this way yeah it's at the
next door
so where those planes gonna be there
every time because I'm not burning them
properly
going well did this start your left
first chat type medium medium your
health insurance didn't clear yay this
is a good day for Mary Oh more shiny
come on I definitely should be able to
there we go
more bullets oh crap oh no there's more
my wasting shells headshot city
population u3 I hear more join your
friends crap I [ __ ] up
all right I think that's it I don't hear
any more shuffling yeah you know what I
will wait [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yes I know I
need that this looks important base
vaccine synthesis well okay
is that it I come back here I guess yeah
I feel like I come back here for a
vaccine bet I get [ __ ] infected with
some hot - [ __ ] mm-hmm god dammit I
know what you're looking for
take it from me this is my husband's
legacy no where's that spy you were
working with earlier you know who I'm
talking about what you really don't know
anything do you he was so gullible she's
one of the operatives sent here by the
agency the only reason why she came here
is to obtain the g-virus that's a lie
yeah no it's the truth I discovered this
when I did a background check on her she
specifically got close to John and
became his girlfriend to get information
about oh she's trying to butter me up I
know her she told me she liked me she
was only I'm not capable of caring but I
care about you you're about to die
anyway
oh my god you did I was really lucky
yeah all right hey careful with that can
I run the Vexin thing and then this door
check it out and then go back downstairs
wait wave time yeah just check the
vaccine thing I could be wrong
yeah ba don't wait wait how much time do
I have you'll be fine oh my god
good save on the way down if you need to
we're on a separate slot try that use
the this sometta motors Gino's g-virus
that one I don't think you can hear I
think I'm getting this out of order okay
yeah just go the store next minute go
downstairs go next door
yeah nothing music
to the left tomorrow just make us long
episode ii to beat it
this way go [ __ ] okay
see your fingerprints verified
yeah
okay their money yeah go mo dis
downstairs so that's right she's gone
but yeah grab some health and [ __ ] on
the way now when you go past the save
box I'm stressed out is this time
limited is it yeah is it what's hope now
she's gonna start a conversation I've
been waiting for you ah [ __ ] what are
you doing give me that give iris so just
hand over the g-virus
I know boys Annette was right I never
got everything that's why I told you to
leave it help me but you wouldn't listen
now hand it over don't make me shoot you
you can't do that uh seems like she's
gonna shoot me Oh
oh [ __ ] whose shards
she
did you say GG virus gg gg virus
shut up you could easily like to make an
except you have a bull in your shoulder
I promised you that we would use your
other hand use my good hand really what
everything
lift her up
Oh
a duh
No
okay clocks running really you know just
got dmal out i'm just tell him it is now
I am this that's true
it is Oh
you pick this stuff up did he just throw
the virus
I go he threw the virus shaft type L
well use the shouting oh that was really
bad I'm injured
where am I going left to right which way
am I going it's your left
I got [ __ ] injured do you have help
yeah I got to double help get that green
water now okay smart you that smart
choose that
ooh that's smart
run kind of slowly down the ladder
didn't-didn't how panic-inducing would
that be to be climbing down that big the
ladder but you know you need to go fast
I would do that slide thing where you
just like hold the sides like a fireman
pulse yeah a fireman shaft you might say
sorry I panicked
that's fine don't shoot at this guy's
legs it's not fine dad my way did I get
hurt again I got hurt again
Butthead
yes
[ __ ] damn I'll just have my computer
didn't-didn't
there's like they're going to the same
room quick
that's just forward right save on a
different slot though why in case I take
you much time
no I mean toward the end this is scary
health and [ __ ] okay so this may be one
curb right bring another herb
this is the end this the end
man this is a stressful time to save
just typing while he's supposed to be
running
should I bring any more guns can't bring
actually get rid of one of those green
herbs and bringing the other first day
it's ready actually kids bring the first
day's big bring the first day spray and
bring another green air but I just use
one of the brightest I may at this point
get out of him okay feel like I'm going
into war charting the trenches
shaft
sup loser sup losers
Oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
ah dude
Oh Oh No oh my god what the [ __ ] is that
should I use my Magnum feel like I
should use my Magnum yeah and run away
first
you hit me
and she like toys and then he'll go away
kind of weave Oh
he's just growing Morty
probably he'll use the greener beneath
the chance oh my god should I heal right
now I checked my phone work [ __ ] but
this is more exciting than whatever
people were slacking me I'm just gonna
what well you have to be like shooting
them on the ceiling nice yeah
mr. Dodge
yeah
[ __ ]
oh my god gum I don't know I don't know
yeah make sure you're not running into
shitty [ __ ] all of it yeah
[ __ ] no he's gonna eat me shoot him
shoot him shoot him but don't change the
camera angle why doesn't it still hit
him yeah it does but I mean like you
don't want to risk it where is he
[ __ ] I found him daddy mr. crappie Tommy
I'm hurt yo up yeah run in the middle
that's the best camera I didn't know
that
oh yeah go down the middle to try to get
him to jump toward you there you go
I would dodge it nice yeah there you go
Oh Oh God
wish I do right you're fine you reloaded
but yeah I just get him to jump for the
middle again I kind of run by him right
on there I feel good about it
oh you're right oh he was you're totally
right
hey guys yes yep yep remembered uh
sprint today you you're good we didn't
have that upgraded Magnum wishes all
right it would have taken it shorter if
you'd up good Megan but you never need
this long as you could dodge with the
Miguel and Iverson all right wrong way
towards it it starts counting two
seconds at a time let's get past
synchronize getting shut up Wei Weis I
don't know I didn't design a laboratory
that's the point of seconds wait where
am I going
che look at the map go dum-dum
the game the game that's not the game
you have another like half an hour
kidding bro
talk about a close call did you know the
cheesy line the end of floor well you
played for before right yeah a bit
better Jeske you look the famous line
see we'll get there it's sure
have you met Sharia
William Internet's daughter yes
just have to find my
Chris this is just Chris is doing is
coating around I catch it right now I
think I don't know like mansion stuff
man Code Veronica and then a few years
later he does 506 goodbye
oh my god you I know that music anyway
yeah sweet nice job three now no I've
took time to go home let's do it
no yeah well sure we could start soon
that was rad mmm-hmm this job yeah he
did it cool oh you had out you had a few
dark episodes there yeah I died a few
times
overall wasn't so bad no cool sweet well
thank you guys for joining us on the
next one we start resi 3 nemesis oh I'm
excited there all right guys